i wonder if the culture war can be
rooted in morality
does the left the like the black lives
matter people do not share the same
morals as most americans no of course
not
but because most americans have
i guess gotten complacent and accepting
they're letting a small faction of
fringe individuals lie to them
push insane policies and just seize
power one
million percent so i find this really
fascinating oftentimes
people will say that public schools are
used to propagandize children and i
couldn't agree with that anymore
but the reality is if you want to
instill your tyrannical philosophy and
the state or in the minds of the average
person
you don't really have to do all that
much work indoctrinating them into your
ideology
all you really have to do is ensure that
they
are raised without any real virtues and
what will happen is as they become
adults they will have been habituated
towards taking the path of least
resistance
in their personal social lives and any
time they're in a situation where
speaking out might become uncomfortable
or make the situation uncomfortable or
unpleasant
they're not going to do it because again
they've habituated themselves towards
doing
what is least difficult and so when you
do have the people you have
indoctrinated into your system
achieving cultural ascendancy they won't
stand up against that
i wonder if you know they call it white
supremacy but i wonder if
that's just first of all i think they
say it's white supremacy and whiteness
as i mean first i said white supremacy
now they say whiteness which is kind of
creepy but
it's it's very obvious they were trying
to change the definition of a word
finding something that people would find
morally repugnant
and then claiming anything they didn't
like was that word
yes and they play with definitions all
the time i wonder if what they're really
going after
is just the the moral foundations of of
christianity that's why
christian morality and that's why that's
why i mentioned that the french
revolution in the the terms right and
left basically come from
a war for or against catholicism and
traditionally catholic values and in the
united states has never been a catholic
nation
but it's been christian and there are
certain principles that
you know protestants and catholics share
and i think those are the ones that are
generally under attack by the far left
at this point in time
and oh sorry to interrupt were you no no
no i just want to drop one more thing
you mentioned earlier about people
saying that they don't need religion in
order to be moral and this is something
i heard time and time again but then
oftentimes these same people will turn
around and say the only case against
abortion is a religious one
okay i was thinking about the french
revolution yeah we had a god they had a
god king
basically the king was god louis was a
king he was god i don't know that he was
a god he
there was a divine right yeah so there
was a prophet there was the divine right
of kings but nobody thought that he was
a god well the french revolutionaries
wanted to undo
god they basically wanted to do away
with church and that was part of it is
get rid of the king get rid of the
church
the start over new let's start a new
calendar knew everything and
they were villainous robespierre was a
psychopath
he gained power and became super
corrupted dan tong was like his
the second in command also a crazy
violent guy
but they overthrew the monarchy which
was
ripping people apart it was starving the
country it was causing
tremendous this is the poverty it's the
pendulum swing
it's you have one really bad situation
and it gives rise to another really bad
situation from really bad people so i
think the black lives matter
see this situation like that even though
i don't think it's that bad at all you
know
it's it's social media and the media yes
creating the perception of chaos
when i mean when then they bring the
chaos
i can't remember someone tweeted this i
can't remember who it was some
high-profile democrats saying like when
will donald trump
i don't know it was like it was like a
news outlet saying
yes there have been riots but donald
trump needs to take responsibility for
the right-wing militias that have been
starting the fights
and it's so insane that's never happened
and so these people
you know what i think it is i think
these people have all fallen into the
toilet whirlpool together
where you've got like imagine this table
right now imagine if i looked at you and
said
hey i heard there were some like crazy
right-wing dudes coming pass it on
and then you looked at ian and said
crazy right-wing dudes are coming pass
it on then ian looks back at me and says
dude we're about to get a wave of crazy
right-wing dudes and then i'm like dude
they're coming
sheamus the right-wingers are about to
be here and it just keeps getting
crazier every time it goes around in a
circle and it was all like me
starting with me going hey do those guys
look like right-wingers to you yep and
then you're like yo tim just saw a bunch
of ringers coming and then you're like
dude right wingers are coming to attack
us and then i'm like
i saw them earlier you're right ian
that's the only thing that explains it
if i saw me now you're saying it
what it really is is they're in a toilet
spinning around in circles yeah the rest
of us are not in that toilet they've
created this perception
and then from it they burst from the
toilet covered in human waste going ah
smashing windows and screaming the end
is nice it's that game
telephone you know you ever play
telephone or you whisper something in
someone's ear then they whisper it they
whisper and then you see how accurate it
is when it gets back to you around the
circle
but i wonder if the people in control of
the news organizations are actually
seeding bad info to create no well
no no no no yeah having having worked at
them i'll tell you what it is
it's a lack of ethics it's a lack of
morality it's a desire for
profits and revenue it's and it's not i
wouldn't necessarily call it
in a malicious intent i would call it
i would call it like it's not willful it
is malicious
but it's the product of the system where
the dude in charge of the money doesn't
know or care about politics
so he sees an article and says whoa that
one got a bunch of clicks
who's donald drumpf i don't know man but
get more people to do whatever that was
then the editor-in-chief is just like
wow you know they're saying we got to
get more of this stuff they look at a
resume so you wrote this donald drumpf's
literally hitler piece
welcome aboard and they shake their hand
and it's not so much that they're being
told to lie
it's not their boss is like we must have
you lie about trump it's like they're
literally sitting there hearing their
own refuse back in their own heads
yeah and so that's the point i was
making imagine if i said to sheamus
i think i saw some right-wing guys and
then he said yo ian
tim said right when guys were coming
then you run to me and go dude
right-wingers are coming here
and then i went whoa i just saw him if
you're saying that too it must be true
that's exactly what's happening in
newsrooms and they keep writing it up
then these leftists who believe all the
media and that's a big divider
in the culture war they believe all this
stuff run around screaming the militias
are coming smashing windows and burning
everything down
and then the media goes did we incite
that let's just not talk about it
they're peaceful
they were peaceful the whole time well
yeah no i hear what you're saying part
of where i'm conflicted here is i tend
to agree with your position which is
that they're caught in these echo
chambers and they don't necessarily mean
to lie but
the story just gets more and more out of
control and they believe that they're on
the quote unquote right side of history
so anything that they say will be
justified
but the narrative also changed really
quickly
once it was obvious that the american
people didn't support the riots and
weren't sympathetic to them at first it
was
well writing is the language of the
unheard and then as soon as
public perception and opinion um as soon
as public opinion towards black lives
matter turned
and they started saying oh it's actually
right-wing agitators so that's why i'm a
little skeptical of the idea
that it just got out of control it just
it seems like a direct
shift based on what they now knew public
opinion was it's
i think the media is blindly chasing
after
whatever works and the democrats just
trust the media
yeah so like mail-in voting is a good
example there was a story in axios today
saying that democrats are pivoting
pivoting away from it now
really yeah yeah it's one story it
doesn't necessarily mean it's true but
there are several organizations now
telling people to go drop your mail off
in person and i see this from a ton of
activists they're saying don't trust the
post office you know things like that
you've got to make sure you mail in
person and and why so late
how is it that the day the story drops
about like
you know primary ballots being discarded
here i am saying wow look primary
ballots got discarded breaking news from
say politico
and then i get all the people watching
it and we all talk about it and the left
is like
what ballots yeah so i i this i know
this guy
and he tweeted he like some some you
know cringe leftist tweeted something
about
uh you know trump is gonna stay jakku
and he's refusing to give up power
and then this guy you know tweeted
where's the lie and my response was
i'm like dude challenging you know
filing a lawsuit about contested belt is
not staging a coup
no telling you know hillary clinton
telling biden not to concede is not
biden staging
coup y'all need to relax and then a
bunch of p and then his response was
what ballots so you mean to tell me it's
been like
three months since the stories broke
about the prime the mailing votes
disappearing or not being delivered
and you didn't know about it you're this
late to the party
and now the democrats finally catch up
so with black lives matter
when uh uh before george floyd died
support for black lives matter was at 17
or 18 percent
net support meaning you know that's like
there's more support than opposition
yeah then george floyd died george floyd
died and it spiked to 25.
today it's at 10. yep it is lower now
than it was before
the george floyd incident because the
democrats were watching the media as a
peaceful protest
just peaceful protesters some peaceful
protesters choose more confrontational
tactics
93 peaceful that's my favorite and they
and they still they still say that stuff
and regular americans are like
why did the guy on tv say it was
peaceful when i literally just got sent
a video of a dude burning down a pawn
shop
or shooting a guy in the chest oh what
were you gonna say well i was just gonna
say it's really funny that they're
talking about this
93 number and i think they've mostly
dropped it i haven't heard it
uh no frequently some espn guy just
spewed it out again
93 of the protests are peaceful 93
percent of serial murders
90 percent of the time serial killers
are peaceful too well in also
yeah i mean seven percent of protests
becoming violent
is a massive number when you're dealing
with a country as large as the united
states
and every major city across it has
protests within it
is a small number and that's right it's
funny because i saw left
saying that oh no you know 93 of them
are peaceful and then i'm not sure where
that metric came from so
i'm not going to say it's wrong to be
skeptical of it but a lot of
right-wingers were saying no this is
fake news from the left it's like
dude even if that's not fake news that's
really high like you're missing the
point seven percent is a lot
i mean it's it's the the fake news about
it is how
they're trying to they're changing the
argument my argument is
wow these violent protests are
horrifying it's too bad they're not like
the peaceful protesters
when the peaceful protesters went on the
bridge and laid down on their stomachs
and put their hands behind their back
and got a bunch of press attention
i said that's awesome i said i disagree
but you know hey man peaceful protest
this country's all about it
then then another group went around
smashing windows and like beating people
and i said well that's terrible
and that was the message we got and then
they instead of arguing
that instead instead of just agreeing
that it's bad
they argued but what about all of the
peaceful protests
nobody's complaining about all the
peaceful protests
that's not the news story we get their
peaceful protests
we don't talk about them because they're
doing what they're supposed to be doing
yeah that's just called the protest
it's funny well yeah this is completely
insane it's completely insane
but when you have you mentioned earlier
this like
i'm sorry i lost my train of thought i
apologize how dare you i know i feel
like this is so
embarrassing don't make fun of me don't
do a venture in person
so he lost his train of thought because
he's an absolute idiot he was thinking
about something related to what
old tim paul just said over there and
then it slipped his mind as soon as he
started talking about him then he
trailed off and it was really
embarrassing so could we please just not
draw attention to it folks okay
it reminds me of like the the family guy
joke of the the vaudeville
piano players and that's yeah quick play
me out and they're like get away
yeah it's over this clip from the tim
cast irl podcast
we do the show live monday through
friday at 8pm so come back to check us
out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for
free if you want to listen to us there
thanks for hanging out and we will see
you all
next time
you